so
what's going on guys this is rob and i
am back
it feels good to be back it feels good
to be making videos again after two
weeks it was just uh
i was starting to get the need i was
starting to get the the need
for speed you know i know that people
love top gun but if i heard anyone say
that in public i would immediately think
they were a douche bag i don't mean to
be a jerk but it's just one of those
lines where like
only douche bags like like fake hyper
masculine douchebags say stuff like that
but uh anyway so um
i'm back and and like i said it feels
good to be making videos again
um but this video is really kind of more
of a question maybe a couple questions
that i have
um i've been thinking about doing like a
vlog slash um
video not in the sense that i'll be
talking about random things but in the
sense that within the video
screen itself you'll have one section of
the screen devoted to
like you know um comic book panels and
then what you've seen so far with my
videos
but there would be another section of
the screen that would have my face my
my beautiful mug talking to you guys and
i don't know if you guys would be
receptive to that kind of thing if you
guys would be interested in that kind of
thing
you know i don't know if that's
something you guys would want to see at
all let me know let me you know leave a
comment let me know or at the very least
i can just do a quick mock-up
and actually do a video that way and
kind of an experiment and
see what you guys think the other thing
is
in a recent comment i said that my next
video was going to be about the infinity
gauntlet
but i'm actually changing that up marvel
recently released some mock-ups and
concept art for
quicksilver and the scarlet witch along
with ant-man
and maybe another person with the
avengers age of ultron film
and i'm thinking about doing a video on
quicksilver and the scarlet witch
because they were really really cool
characters the scallop which of course
kicked off the house of m and was the
reason for the avengers disassembled
story lines
uh as a quick explanation the scarlet
witch kind of loses her mind she goes
crazy
and ends up killing a few of the
avengers i think she kills hawkeye
and um the avengers end up disassembling
because of all the stuff that tony stark
got into he can't afford to bankroll the
avengers anymore and so they kind of
split up
and the house of am is where she full
bore goes off the deep end
and ends up altering reality when she
changes it back she says no more mutants
and so when reality goes back to normal
like 99 percent of all mutants lose
their powers it's absolutely crazy like
the kind of storyline that comes into
play
um but i don't know if you guys would be
interested in in you know a video about
the scarlet witch explaining this call
at which because of course we talk about
bova
we talk about uh wonder mountain the
high evolutionary different things like
that because
there were some pretty cool characters
that were involved with regards to
um the adventures of the scarlet witch a
quick silver in addition to them
actually being raised from birth to
you know adolescence and into adulthood
so um
let me know what you guys think about
that kind of thing and uh again it is
good to be back i will catch you guys
later
peace